we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
hey hey folks here we are we're here
we're drunk it's uh
it's it's we might be drunk we might be
what do you got a dunkaroo this is the
best dunkaroo there's someone sent this
in the vanilla frosting one this is this
is my childhood we've gone full special
needs on this show we're all in here oh
man this is like a handy snack that's
good
holy [ __ ] god damn that's pure
jizz and that is so good um well i
swallowed did you do handy snacks or was
that a southern thing what's handy
snacks again what
with the cheese and crackers oh yeah
those are good yeah no that's not a
southern thing okay i just forgot yeah
yeah the little uh red stick yes
that was every mom's nightmare because
they were in that bin right by the
register and i was like come on mom
they're like 14 cents he was like all
right you're putting you know
horrible things in your body but [ __ ]
it was just anthrax and [ __ ] you know
isis sent that one to the pentagon
exactly oh gal gadot is that what you
pulled up now the yeah so she remember
that song she did at the beginning of
kovid when it was like she did imagine
yeah so she just apologized for it good
she said it was toned down
i hate when people apologize for stuff
but this warranted an apology oh it was
so cringy so gross when all the
celebrities were singing imagine that
was one thing about the pandemic was
celebrities just became so
off-putting like we all knew celebrities
are out to lunch they're up in their
ivory tower in hollywood jerking each
other off but the pandemic they all just
they had no movie roles so they just got
online and were annoying and dorky
it was like less about us and more about
them yes and my wife stacy was like this
is what happens when they're out of the
limelight for five minutes they need
attention they need it so they put
themselves out there in the weirdest
ways it all comes back to narcissism
it's toned marley matlin was like that
was toned down that was
that was rough that it's one of those
things where you're like first off my
friend joe mackey would always say that
imagine is a bad song which i think is
hilarious and i i used to laugh and like
okay it's john lennon but then i i
listen to the lyrics i'm like it is kind
of bad is it what's bad about it it's
just kind of horse [ __ ] it's kind of not
saying anything it's just kind of like
imagine things were good well it's also
coming from a zillionaire yeah you know
imagine there's no possessions i'm like
you live in a mansion with a white piano
you imagine there's no possessions yeah
you want to live like us you imagine
exactly and you're
apparently hitting your wife i've heard
yeah well i think his first wife oh he
hit his first wife he couldn't hit yoko
she was bobbing and weaving
his first wife sang imagine imagine you
didn't hit me
imagine there's no black eye
dude these dunkaroos are you [ __ ]
kidding me away from me get them away
from me that's like cocaine that is
hilarious when people say get them away
get my ats yeah i can't do it they're
good
yeah that's not good for you that is
pure like grade a right to the vain
sugar columbiano yes that's the stuff
the good stuff you know
i saw this [ __ ] on narcos
how does it like taste like your
childhood is that what you're like
taking sugar
that that is high octane horseshit right
there here that is [ __ ] delightful
yeah i can't believe we give that to
children they're going to be on them
this is frosting it's just frosting it's
frosting yeah dude so good it's so good
frosting [ __ ] rules frosting's great
paula tompkins is a great joke he's like
what's better cake or pie he's like cake
because after you eat frosting you feel
shame
well dude frosting have you ever i
remember you know when i was like a kid
being like college we'd have like frosty
in the fridge because we're [ __ ]
degenerates and oh yeah then you eat it
just straight you're high as [ __ ] and
then you look at the back of the serving
size and you're like
get me a shotgun right yes exactly well
did i just consume 5 000 calories in
like four spoons i know how the hell did
i do this i know and then you're like
wait a minute and a tooth falls out i
mean that [ __ ] is evil
evil
damn dude that was a big trope in the
90s was uh like women would get sad and
they would just eat a box of bonbons
i think that went away before
antidepressants yes yes exactly sugar
that'll help right you want to kill
yourself have a malamar yeah stress
eating was big it's still big
it's two years of a pandemic it's
[ __ ] big every uh bridgette jones
diary or sex in the city they had a
breakup and they'd eat haagen-dazs like
out of the cart and that was always a
big cliche i like bridget jones diary
yeah that i think it's good aren't there
a few of them i think like two or three
two yeah i like old old sex in the city
is killer so good that's a great show
the new one have you seen the new one oh
yeah
they'll be apologizing for that in the
year i mean that show is a nightmare
those jokes you apologize for and then
there's content yeah i apologize exactly
i'll apologize for the if i won't but
the offensive [ __ ] i'd rather get [ __ ]
for than just horseshit cringy
you know fluff that they're doing i
heard chris knowth even cancel was like
thanks for killing me off early
that was pretty rough i know i love how
transparent they are with like
how the first transfer right oh my god
the first 10 seasons of this we didn't
have one minority and now it's like
we're all pairing off with our new best
friends and each one happens to be a
minority
he's like
okay yeah the kids are trans the wife's
a lesbian
miranda was like the smart one she was a
lawyer and all this now she's just ditzy
and [ __ ] she's like oh yeah i love
this woman now and i'm with my husband
but [ __ ] him it's is that what happened
i i quit after half an hour now hanging
up with a non-binary woman a non-bearing
person the writing is bad and then it's
like we hate men but this woman acts
like a man so she's cool you know
they were they really [ __ ] up i'm not
talking about miranda i'm talking about
the writers
yeah today
uh no it's [ __ ] dog [ __ ] what i saw
and i i i'm with you i like sex in the
city it was like a weird comfort wash
for me on the road because it was so new
york so if it was on tbs or some [ __ ]
and i was in a hotel room i'm like yeah
it's new i'm in [ __ ] you know
florida yeah comfort watch you know it
was so new york was all soho tribeca it
was great the brownstones
she lived uh sarah jessica parker i
don't want to give out her address but
she lives in the village and i can see
her house all day it's great
she uh she's one of us she's awesome and
she i love sarah jessica parker
new york and then but then also you
don't bring back i watched the beginning
of sex in the city and the way they talk
about samantha is like the funniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen where they're like look
like she just changed like it's you know
sometimes people it's clearly about the
actress yeah but they're like you know
sometimes you lose touch with people and
they don't know what your friendship
meant sometimes your agent wants more
money
that's the most realistic plot line is
the fact that these women can't get
along
[Laughter]
melanie had that great joke he's like
there's ocean's 11 with a bunch of dudes
robbing back there could be no oceans
left with women because four would pair
off to talk [ __ ] about the other six so
and then but then they made it they did
make it they did he made that joke
before and
yeah
but uh yeah man it is
hilarious that they were like well we
gotta talk [ __ ] about her
we'll do it but also she was the best
character she was hilarious she was the
comic relief by far
yeah you cut out the funny person cut
out the [ __ ] girl she was great
now now here now here's a big dude
question
who's the hottest ranking in your mind
sex in the city yeah like who's the
prettiest or most sexy or whatever you
want to say i mean samantha was probably
one just because she was the biggest
[ __ ] yeah and she was the funniest yeah
yeah i mean she was like she was the
wittiest i thought yeah for sure how
about you
i got a weird crush on i know you're
gonna say sarah jessica parker sjp i
knew you'd say it i love that
crazy mug i love her free-wheeling fun
attitude i love the crazy hair i love
her outfits i think she's so sexy for me
it's big
me personally i'm an aiden man yeah um
no it's uh who would have thought we'd
talk about this [ __ ] on the podcast
don't tell me yeah don't tell me you
don't have levels on this podcast we're
talking about sex in the city well the
show is good if it's good it's good it
is good and it's like cheesy in a fun
way yes well like the writing's a little
punny and cheesy at times but i still
kind of liked it
it's a comfort watch yeah but
yeah man i don't know like uh
i yeah i gotta go
here's the thing about charlotte like on
paper very hot good looking lady but
you know she's not doing [ __ ] in the
bedroom she's a boy
i'm never the character not the i met
her actually in a diner once when i was
in like seventh grade maybe eighth grade
and i remember uh i went up to her i was
with my friends we were in like our show
sex in the city at the time yeah and i
was in my basketball uniform we were all
coming from practice and i saw her in a
diner because we were just like getting
like a soda i was like getting like a
coke or something and she uh i was a kid
i i said to her yeah i don't think she
was turned on she's like look at that
eighth grader with one eyebrow i know
basketball shorts can't hide a boner
well i said to her oh i watch your show
all the time and she goes no you don't
you're too young and then i go yeah then
how come i know your husband can't get
it up and the whole diner laughed it was
like a big laugh oh that's a great
moment and she laughed really hard okay
i gotta laugh at her wow that's great
yeah that's huge put you on the road to
being a comic
fast trick baby
just uh just about 20 years and i was on
my way
but no she uh
i don't know no samantha was super cool
but you're right the writing was a
little over the top but it worked it
worked it worked samantha'd be like i
tried anal last night but you know when
i go to the club i always go in the back
door
i can ride that show in my sleep
but i liked it but it was also uh look
how pretty come on there was also
nothing like that on air no that's why
it's like you could say whatever about
it but it's like there was nothing like
it yeah i used to work at a restaurant
in baton rouge louisiana and i was the
only guy waiter was a bunch of ladies
and they were they would talk about that
show all day and all night and it was
fascinating to hear them talk about that
show because they're like
they talk about sucking dick like we
talk about it you know it was fun to
watch them love the show
and i was like do you guys want to go on
a date they're like ugh
[Laughter]
you watch it to get laid yeah yeah
pretty much
this is really just for sam but
she's an episode of colombo and she's in
porkys she's in porky she's the one
she's the streamer gym teacher yeah
let's see this yeah
ordinarily peter [ __ ]
just before what year
probably 77. well you're swimming
colombo comes back he's like there's
just one more thing that's bothering me
did you do you suck my dick
god how old was she i guess see we
forget that the 90s is only 20 years
after the 70s ooh you know like the
2000s is 20 years ago now it was
probably the 80s no no 70s 70s yeah yeah
the 90s were still close to the 70s like
i would watch reruns of [ __ ]
gilligan's island when i was a kid well
she's probably like early 20s here i
remember she's in the pool in this
episode too not today
not that you uh jerked off to it twice
today
hey
damn she was just her whole career was
like yeah i'm down
i'm dtf but then i heard you
i heard she had divorced because uh she
wouldn't [ __ ] her husband enough like
his complaint was like they didn't have
enough sex and she's like i was playing
a character ah
that's gotta be a bummer when you're
like you're like i saw you on that show
like you want to go have sex she's like
no i'm an actress i don't i don't just
want to [ __ ] everybody right
it is crazy like i i rewatched some of
the old show just to get the taste out
of my mouth to the new one and it's
pretty
quote unquote problematic you know is it
oh yeah but fun in a fun way they're
like
i'm gonna [ __ ] a black guy on this
episode the rest of them are like whoa
jesus slow down
you know when you when you blew that
that hobo in the hallway that was one
thing but a black guy
and uh it was like that black don't
crack well you should see my butthole oh
my god there you go
i think mark and i could write for this
[ __ ]
darren starr are you listening
a lot of comics on too i think what was
it gaffigan todd barry god yeah todd
barry was on yeah
yeah he talked about it when he was on
here oh must've been drinking
but what about yeah i mean there's so
many comics showing that show but uh
damn i mean yeah it was a different i
mean you watch entourage episodes now
you watch certain shows and you're like
holy [ __ ] i mean oh yeah times have
changed that's how [ __ ] works though
that's how [ __ ] works yeah exactly and
it's it's normal it's okay and i
i think we're still those people we just
have more information now we have more
different feedback we have different
voices speaking to us and going that
bothered me like oh okay because we have
social media we have the internet we
have all this so
i think we're all still
animals
we just know more yeah well it wasn't
twitter when sex and the city came out
the first time exactly now it's like you
know sex in the city now it's like i
didn't get to the comic i heard the
comic on the show was like wow
oh dude it'll take you you guys made it
further than i i literally made it like
20 minutes in the episode and then i
heard big died having a heart attack and
i was like [ __ ] you yeah
he deserves i mean maybe maybe the actor
didn't deserve better but the character
did yes here here i mean
i know what an ad for pelton then they
have an ad about it uh they were
[ __ ]
their stock dropped eleven percent i
know he died on the pelicans i thought
it was a weird choice to have kevin
spacey did the new commercial
but i he
yeah it's like what are you what are you
doing yeah i guess that you need what is
she like dating in the new episodes is
that why they needed that exactly
like i'm in the 10th episode she just
started dating
but it's it's such a [ __ ] up show
because i watch it and i don't give
anything away but carrie starts dating
this guy and he's like an older white
guy and i'm like you're going to date an
older white guy what are you crazy
oh wait you're poising my brain now
you know like that's weird that i see an
older white guy i'm like bad bad
stranger danger but that's that's the
show yeah don't watch the stand-up thing
i don't want you to get tainted i had to
watch it through like fingers like this
it was horrible
well
that's how the industry views stand up
but it's like eight minutes of this
trans woman i'm not trans she's
non-binary woman or person and she's
just
going for applause no jokes yes just
trying to get feedback like where are we
at with uh my trans people and just
applause applause plus so they kind of
nailed it no jokes
manhattan is not supposed to be where
you pander this is supposed to be a
blunt city where you just connect
through like we're blunt
cruel people that's new yorkers and
that's not because we're actually cruel
like when you really need i remember 9
11 when we lined up for you know can we
donate blood literally everyone in the
city's like can we donate blood that was
what we did
and too many people lined up so you're
like you can't i mean too many people
already offered but you know
that's the thing about new yorkers but
like when it push comes to shove with
that we got your back but in little
moments we can be casually
uh not compassionate like
if you see a crazy person to train you
don't have time to be like his life must
be terrible i i oh my god like where did
he go wrong you think move
right that's because you don't have time
to think about that forever it's too
fast paced the city he's and he's the
third one today you've seen exactly you
got to keep moving yeah exactly or your
whole life would just be like oh my god
we got to stop here louie's got that
great joke about his friend from like
omaha comes here there's a homeless guy
laying there smelling like [ __ ] and
she's like we have to help this guy he's
like what
we're going to eat no sweetie we don't
do that here yeah yeah exactly right
right such a good point but it's like
that's the thing is that
we are good people here but that's our
humor is not like
how are you doing that's not new york no
that's just not new york it doesn't mean
we don't care it just doesn't mean like
that's a great point they've brought la
to this show
the show used to be a new york show but
that's not real the la show like how are
you of course do they [ __ ] care no
they don't care either la's weird their
priorities are all out of whack they're
like hey we have to help everybody you
know and then like they have the most
homeless in the country like what about
them they're like oh we don't worry
about them we're worried about
non-binary whatever the worst homeless
because they all have head shots they
still think they're going to make it
25 of all homeless people are in
california
well the weather's great and 50 percent
of
california homes people are in los
angeles
damn wow yeah how do you like that crazy
that's crazy and do you know that 40 of
them were in la la land the movie
crazy they can sing and dance they're
more talented than our homeless yeah
that's true uh no it's crazy man you
know uh
california is weird because i love
california i got san diego san francisco
i love it la's weird la's weird well i
feel like l.a caught up with its own
[ __ ] you know because it was all
about me me me and you forgot about the
little guy and now the little guy is
growing and you don't know what to do
you're overwhelmed and a lot of people
left peter dinklage took growth hormone
that's what happened
but uh yeah i'm with you man that city
really uh
it is a little up his own ass oh yeah
little
it's why i started catching on fire they
were like i can't handle this [ __ ] yeah
that's god trying to save it let's burn
this [ __ ] guys like get the [ __ ] out of
here
if you guys got a sitcom how long could
you i could do it i'd do it like
probably two months yeah i could do a
month or two months two or three months
is that short or long that's short to me
i mean because i feel like i did five
months during the pandemic but that was
the pandemic yeah that was the beginning
and we kind of didn't know how i mean
that was when people were still wiping
down groceries we didn't [ __ ] know we
didn't know what was going on it was a
weird time i mean so like
with my actual life la's hard for me for
so many reasons like it's hard to do the
road out of because if you're going to
the midwest there's the time change
we're going to the east coast we work a
lot in the east coast you know so
uh the business is technically still out
there but also like we can kind of make
our own business yes we do this podcast
it's gonna get more youtube views and
probably if we do stand up on fallon you
got that right right like and fallon's
like the big late night show so you have
to think like the way it's good to do
everything but you have to look at the
way shit's going right
so um
yeah and everybody's like wait we have
the beach i'm like but you don't go
we have the beach here we don't go i
mean it's winter but like we got
beautiful beaches the rockaways are
great long long beach is great but
nobody goes there taylor asked me she's
like why don't you ever take me to the
beach in new york i was like uh what do
we have to bury a body what the hell
exactly the beach on the east coast we
don't go but it's beautiful the surfers
out there doing [ __ ] all all summer long
we don't go so there's a really nice
beach called orchard beach it's in the
bronx and it's mostly trans people yeah
yeah well that'll go
interesting
we should go we should go i would love
it i've never been to brighton beach i'm
a new yorker i just kind of don't
venture out that much i'm kind of i'm
kind of boring it's the same as coney
island just less people well it's
russian jews over there right
i kind of want to go there just for the
food i'll i'm down with it i love it we
should do an episode there
episode road trip dryden beach yeah some
russian food some borscht i [ __ ] love
russian food dude i'll get the beamer
out we'll uh we'll do a road really film
it yeah
all right let's do it let's do it matt
you get you in we'll strap you to the
hood
we're trying to get through a tunnel it
just keeps hitting
well that's the thing about new york is
like there's so much variety and
different [ __ ] and geography that we
just don't touch we have our little hub
we go i go to 14th to houston that's it
yeah we have a little hamster trails we
go to and then back and that's it that's
it it's tough i mean we kind of get very
comfortable in new york and it's also
like dude especially in the winter it's
time when it's 10 degrees out it's like
what do you um here's what i do i do my
comedy i i have some soup like what the
[ __ ] else i'm boring [ __ ] i'm falling
asleep over here
and you read you listen to classical
some jazz oh speaking of read i took you
up on a wreck because you talked about
bernie brillstein's book pretty good
book right it's great it's an easy i
listen to the audiobook oh because
his voice is hilarious is that right
here's why i read it by the way our
buddy simon rex who's in red rocket
which you should all go see i gotta
watch it i gotta i got a copy simon rex
text me
you know i love he likes the podcast a
lot and he goes you know i uh
i loved i loved the the brillstein book
you react and i said i didn't reckon he
goes mark did i guess then i was like oh
i should listen to it then he goes
listen to the audio book because it's
like his voice is amazing yeah so i'm
listening to it and i'm like it's so you
know an audiobook is good when you can
just sit there and listen and not do
anything else yes so so many good
insider entertainment uh audiobooks i
mean he's a classic is that him this is
him oh jim henson's memorial i don't
know what this is i pulled up oh yeah he
wrapped jim henson all right did you
hear this yeah you read the book you
know that uh
i guess i skipped that [ __ ]
oh he's riffing hold on oh i knew that i
knew that we never to follow the bird
he's killing at a funeral
look at that funeral oh my god it's so
grand that's like a schumer gig
[Laughter]
is that the six and i temple jesus
ah
i'm bernie brostein i've been jim's
friend and manager for 30 years
i gotta laugh in a business
with the one who shouts the loudest
usually gets the most attention
jim henson rarely spoke above a whisper
you had to lean in to hear him most of
the time
but it was always worth the effort
david laser and i knew how loud his
whisper was
he was a man with a vision
and though his greatest appeal
was the simplest of human emotions
the purest of ideas
he was not above using
with advanced technological means to
achieve his goal except to save his own
life
my friend jim was by most definitions of
genius
but not like edison suggested
edison said genius was one percent
inspiration
and 99 perspiration oh jim
i think it was about 50 50.
i think his voice is that weird
in the book he's a little older oh okay
so he's like sweating while reading you
could tell he's just like
and
right then chapters are starting
so i say go [ __ ] yourself i mean talk
about new york i mean this guy
grew up in new york he meets elvis yeah
he meets elvis and he sells the photo
that story is amazing it's just old
showbit copacabana all that [ __ ] amazing
incredible stuff great stuff great story
uh texting with gary goldman about it
today because gary goldman always our
buddy
another wreck yeah the great gary
goldman if you if a lot of people are
dealing with depression right now gary's
got one of the best specials about it
yeah funny it's called the great
depression on hbo last night it's
incredible it's an incredible special
and gary's an incredible guy and uh
i love him he uh
he he wrecks me books all the time
because gary is like the most
avid reader i know and uh
he was talking about this book and we
talked about like chan lane because he
came off kind of bad and gary's like i
don't know i kind of side with gary but
i heard he was a mixed bag at best i
don't know sure it's a great book all
right so i appreciate it thanks yeah i'm
i'm loving it i'm reading sapiens too
and i just find myself going back to
brillstein because he's so fun he's so
likable and it's new york fun [ __ ] where
sapiens is like and then the
the crowmagnet went for the stick and
you're like all right give me some fun
density is tough for us because our
minds wander yes i do think like uni
entertainment is so naturally
interesting to us because it's it's our
world you know i was talking so much
about business and and the evolution of
business and how like
you know
when a guy's in management for 50 years
you watched the business change so many
times and we're kind of watching that
right now so he talks about hbo coming
along right and how like he's one of his
lines in the book is that you know
man lenny bruce would have killed for
hbo and you're like that's pretty heavy
that's right true you think about that
like you die out in the 60s you can't
say [ __ ] hbo like say whatever you want
subscription-based services starting
even then you can kind of see that
advertised based
uh television was kind of going away
it's kind of wrong yeah interesting
thought today which was so much of a
joke is timing
and so much of a comic's career is
timing so true
i've had so many agents be like if you
were born in the 80s you'd be huge yeah
and i'm like oh yeah maybe you're right
but you got to cope with whatever time
you're in i mean but also you can make
the most of whatever time you're in you
can still figure it i mean we're in a
weird time
because mark and i are kind of old
school comics you know like
[Music]
not a lot of comics our age have done a
lot of late night sets like us we're
kind of cut from that old school cloth
but
that's not the word we live in anymore
so
you have to adapt but like look we have
adapted yeah yeah we're tick-tocking
we're youtubing we're instagramming
we're trying we're podcasting
we're doing what we got to do well what
did you mean when you said things are
changing because i don't think that's
what you meant well
kind of what he talked about i mean the
subscription-based model is king now i
mean it's like cable was king for a
while i mean you had a show on cable you
were huge right huge and now look at
cable i mean cable's a joke uh now it's
like you want to be on netflix or hulu
or amazon or hbo or some [ __ ] like that
you don't want to be on you don't want
to be on like
you know
tbs or comedy central right but in your
careers in your just the 15 years you've
been doing it comedy has changed the way
stand-up comedy comics tell jokes has
changed it's not
you guys are a joke guys both of you are
joke guys there are complete story guys
there are people who are like just
talking about their lives in like a
depressing way not goldman i'm talking
about like talking about like uh gatsby
yeah it's like there's not a lot of
jokes here i mean you can tell jokes but
she's telling the story of her pain like
that's not comedy
right as you know it well yeah the doors
have been opened also to a lot of new
stuff yeah but i think he's saying
you got a comedy central special back in
the day you were set
we both have those we both have multiple
tonight shows
it doesn't mean moon the needle
so it's changing the way of like you
have to make your own path now
so when um
fallon or someone comes to you now do
you drop everything like you used to you
give them the benefit out you go back
maybe i will but if they start going you
can't do that joe can't do that you're
like well this is not even worth it
anymore once you start taking up too
much of your time you're kind of like i
mean
the comics don't get the same respect as
like don't have guests or let the like
panel guest do whatever the hell they
want for the most part but like
you so how often do you see like a panel
guess like can i say [ __ ] and they
already said it like they're messing
with the host but then we say like fart
and they're just like what you can't say
fart yeah people you know that's
offensive to our advertisers you know
like we're still the bottom feeders over
there so it's kind of like we've been
disrespected our whole career so you do
kind of there's a party that's kind of
like i don't really need this but if
they if they don't make it too hard on
you then it's still fun to do yeah i
mean look i'll take you're right we get
disrespected we're the bottom feeders
we're we're nobodies of show business
but i'll take that
and be myself i'd rather be myself
than play the game and be more famous
you know i'd rather i think comics have
a
a gift and a curse where we get to be
honest and keep it real and say some
truths in society and call out [ __ ]
and then the the penalty is you don't
get to be
jim carrey which i'm fine with
does that make sense sure i mean i don't
think like i think it's an even trade
and i'll take it yeah yeah i mean it's
kind of nice to kind of control your own
destiny a little bit which i think guys
coming up back in the day like
mark can attest to this you know when we
started i remember recording sets on vhs
tapes oh yeah comics you sent a tape in
like i would you didn't now you send a
[ __ ] link yeah when i started out it
was like here's let me go to the post
office let me go to a store where i can
make a copy of a tape yeah i'd have to
go to a store to make a copy of a vhs so
it's like the game has changed so much i
mean i remember
in college getting a gig because i like
handed someone a dvd of myself it's just
so different i know youtube has changed
so much i'm such an old [ __ ] that like
i'll have my friend he does video stuff
i'm like can you can you edit this put
captions on it and he'll put a graphic
in of like i'll say some joke about
harry potter and he's there's a picture
of harry potter and i'm like whoa
how'd you do that holy [ __ ] that was
incredible the harry potter thing good
for you
and i'll put on instagram and i'll get
like eight likes i'm like what i got a
harry potter meme in there what are you
kidding
so yeah i'm we're i'm out to lunch i'm
old
yeah but we're trying to cling on
cling on star trek but yeah
working on it we're trying we're
hustling that's why it annoys me like i
can't get what can i take out for coffee
and get some tips i'm like ah you're way
off you should be grinding already don't
worry about what i'm doing go figure it
out yeah pick the brain is a weird thing
i hate this can i pick your brain it
doesn't even sound good no it sounds
painful can i pick your brain like that
doesn't sound pleasant pick my nose
get back to work go write something
get out of here you're not gonna get any
tidbits for me i'll just take out the
lunch i'll waste my day and go you gotta
ride a bunch you gotta bomb you gotta
hit the road you gotta get on stage
that's it
it's scary they just want comfort i get
that i get it i do i you do want you i
try to respond if people are like but
you know how many can you respond to it
yeah without because the problem isn't
just respond to one it's like once you
get on the phone it's hard to get back
off and try to write again yeah so it's
not just like resp it's like it would
take 30 seconds to respond you're like
right but then that 30 seconds disrupts
the flow it's time exactly so
you can set time aside but it's not uh
it's not easy
but they just want the reassurance they
want the reassurance you'll be okay i
get it i don't know if you'll be okay
it's it's very difficult yes uh i can't
tell you anything but when people send
you like
i had a guy asked me to like go go
through his notebooks or something i was
like i don't have time to do that [ __ ]
like that's homework well it's just a
lot of work i'm like if i'm gonna do
that that's like that's like a job yeah
and i hate to say it but there's
thousands hundreds of thousands of hours
of podcasts about comedy
i think that's more valuable go listen
to some of that [ __ ] than me going out
and getting a cup of coffee with you
they probably just want to meet you
well then that's even weirder
i got nothing for you i'm a german i'm a
grump i'm a [ __ ] i got nothing for you
yeah you're pretty nice all right i try
to be nice i'll take a photo with you
but that that's not that's not what you
need if you really want to be a comedian
go go go for it the best way to do it is
really
just going out and doing the work and us
finding you that way is so much more
satisfying too isn't it like you know if
we're like oh [ __ ] this guy we're on the
show with this guy this guy's funny
totally that's satisfying like
um i'm watching uh ian laura on stage
last night the seller and he's got funny
jokes and louie is in the doorway
laughing i'm like that's what you want
that's what you want is like a comedy
legend to be like laughing did you tell
ian that i didn't i should oh he'll hear
that i didn't i didn't uh i didn't i was
we passed each other as we were going on
so i didn't i didn't get a moment to be
like
louie's laughing
i was like literally walking the stage
and we passed each other that would mean
a lot to him he's he's he's a real comic
yeah so that's big
yes but that's that's how you want to
get that [ __ ] yes
i think but it's also like i get the
needing like we were needy mark i mean
we we were needy too i mean that's just
kind of how it goes you're needy you're
desperate until you're kind of calm yeah
who's the first person that listened to
you
like
gripe or like gave you anything well we
had each other we had a lot of we had a
big class of of losers okay just like
guys who didn't know what the [ __ ] we
were doing but and he means big comics
so i think he's that many big comics not
like oh so allow you to like hang on and
be like
whose brain did you pick well i was
lucky enough that i was taken out by
schumer who was his big star but i also
had to play it safe because she's kind
of no nonsense so i had to like not
annoy her but it was so good for you
that you just kind of socially knew how
to handle that yeah but i'll tell you
her seinfeld all these comics the main
thing i got from them was i'm using you
because i can tell you give a [ __ ] i can
tell you're trying i can tell you care i
can tell you're working hard energy
didn't annoy her and that
but that's what i wanted to do earlier
so
i think a lot of a lot of advice is
don't be annoying
don't bother people and if we see you
doing the work
that'll come through
yeah and that means more to us because
it means you give a [ __ ] you're not just
trying to short shortcut this [ __ ]
yeah do the work first for me
jeez it's tough i don't know the first
was i mean gary goldman helped me a lot
early on david tell helped me a lot
early on amy obviously helped me as well
you know it's certain comics just like
tom papa tom papa was big for you i
remember even greg barron helped early
on with you greg bear and tommy john
again by the way yeah so certain people
you know uh like i remember goldman i
opened form
uh on the road just by chance i remember
they asked me to do another week and i
was like i'd rather work with gary
goldman i'm a fan of his stuff and they
were like okay and i so i met him and i
got to and we had mutual friend ryan
hamilton and gary was very nice i was
very nervous opening for him because i
liked his stuff and oh yeah
and it got off and the second i got off
stage he goes you're gonna be my first
wreck at the comedy seller hey so that
was like that man i didn't believe it i
was kind of like you know you're so
beaten down by the business at that
point you're kind of like i believe when
i see it but it meant a lot that was his
way of saying i was funny to him and uh
and he he followed through with it but
uh
yeah gary davitel was very helpful you
know remember we're shooting our dock
full capacity and this didn't make the
cut but we were interviewing ronnie
chang and he said
i came to new york and i was a wannabe
comic i wasn't at the cell i was there
to watch comedy and i saw sam and i was
like i know this guy he's a great comic
and he said you really opened up to him
and like told him about the scene and i
don't remember it at all i really don't
remember i think ronnie's a great comic
and i love him he's like he's my buddy
and he's now very kind and for no reason
why didn't i didn't know him i just if
you're he was nobody he was just a guy
visiting new york well
if you're just cool and chill i'm kind
of just like what the hell i'm not gonna
hang out with anybody but i also like
that's great i mean he's i think he's i
love ronnie chang he's like my he's my
good buddy now great guy uh and he's and
he's such a good comic but i mean um
yeah it's funny i remember he said that
i was kind of like you don't remember
[ __ ] yeah yeah well
so much crazy [ __ ] all day long every
day it all blends together
yeah plus asians you know they look
alike but yeah
but then he uh
this is getting a little sappy now
you're right he's doing it we've been
drinking we've been drinking buddy well
he uh also uh
i can't imagine moving from another like
i grew up here so i can't imagine moving
from
i mean [ __ ] ronnie was in like singapore
and australia right i can't imagine
coming from canada right i can't imagine
coming from baltimore jersey yeah
nola baby yeah that's terrifying but i
remember this talk about starting out
and new people i remember hanging out
with ali wong and she was like confiding
in me like ah i kill for a credit just
give me a credit just give me like a
montreal or you've seen them i've seen
her on the jay leno whatever i would
kill for any credit comedy central and
then cut to like 10 years later she's
doing theater she's the biggest thing on
netflix you know moms at offices are
like i love this ali wong lady she's
hilarious
huge movies now
and it just i rewind back to her in the
back of broadway comedy club in a
montreal audition going like i just want
to credit just give me something god
broadway comedy club we need some rough
nights
boy talk about
disrespectful i got that's where i got
spat on there you go you told that story
already but yeah and that's when you got
into that
it happens
you guys want to answer some questions
yeah let's just let's use it and make
sure to email us for our patreon because
we do this all the time on the patreon
at uh we might be drunk pod gmail.com uh
patreon.com we might be drunk pod but
yeah let's do some we do we do questions
we do we'll listen to your jokes we'll
do uh
cocktail recommendations peeves racks
whatever the [ __ ] you want there's also
a special tube here for you guys oh oh
yeah let's check it out all right should
we do that now first or should we do
that yeah i'm trying to keep it to the
tube
all right this is from sally as a gift
yeah all right all right
oh boy
oh boy you really like it be delicate
you're delicate
treat it like the [ __ ] mark yeah i can't
find it
there we go big papa
little good
yeah whoa
that's a classic
that's good dude
wow
where's that india
no i hadn't did in manhattan oh really
yeah wow look at that
do we get it framed or do we just kind
of throw it up like that yeah you frame
it we go amazon we'll measure it we can
get a frame in here in two days
oh man that's great what year is this
this was during the during the pandemic
that was like six months ago probably
yeah wow
well i'm i'm nervously looking over my
setlist mark's praying to allah
and uh
yeah i do it five times a day
thank you sally all right
so i got uh that's great dylan here with
some
mark and sam impressions oh i can't wait
you all ready let's see all right
greetings from boise idaho um here's two
jokes one uh is mark the other one is
sam
so the word on the street is that people
prefer pedophiles were forced to enlist
and fight the war for us
the only issue with that is who would be
running the country oh boy
the old boys spot on i don't get the
joke
but
but it is like uh
it's a very cartoony mark yeah yeah it's
not like a dead on like like mateo or
something like a godfrey but it's like a
cartoony it's funny
see what he's got in store for you
second one is sam
is this true certain brands of deodorant
console alzheimer's
the only problem with that is i couldn't
tell you what brand i've been using
that's amazing
but it's funny how people perceive us it
is funny it's like uh
we don't know ourselves in some ways
like people like i was talking to taylor
about this earlier is like she said like
we see so many pictures of ourselves
that we don't even know how we look
that's true because she was talking
about how like
we get photographed looking really good
like done up for a special we get
photographed like at some show we wore
sweatpants to like we see each other
from every bad and good angle yeah it's
hard to have
a real perception of ourselves you know
i agree they i read some study that said
if you saw yourself on the street you
wouldn't recognize it would take like a
double take be like oh is that me oh
[ __ ] because we also that's cause you're
a clone that'd be weird
but we also see each other the way we
want to see each other or see ourselves
the way we want to see ourselves like
you ever see like a really ugly fat guy
in the mirror like oh yeah every day
[Laughter]
and you're like why is this guy
impressed he's hideous but he sees what
he wants to see and we kind of we kind
of do that with our brains a little bit
mark uh i've been drinking all day and
you're looking better and better hey
thank you [ __ ] looks like paul
rudd over here look at that i'll take it
all right paul mud so we have one more
here
jimbo slice nice anything inspired by a
movie tv show and here's his
what up y'all
want to see what drinks you recommend
based off of film or television
uh i saw donald glover have a fridge
connection in atlanta um and you know so
now on occasion i will drink a hennessy
and grand marnier
let me know what you guys are drinking
based off of a movie
well i don't know if i've ever done that
it was funny este the booker the comedy
seller that that was her drink the
french connection what is that i've
never heard of that it's like it's kind
of hot isn't it look up the ingredients
that's a hot drink i think you just said
it
and something yeah or is that something
else no that's it i think i think you
can heat it up a little great name
french connection it sounds badass yeah
good movie great movie
sheen hackman [ __ ] rules popeye doyle
new york city and uh what's his name
from jaws in greece
he's great
one and a half ounces cognac one ounce
amaretto oh that's like a that's like a
black drink well that warms you up
filled with ice
a black drink that's very urban
what the hell does that even mean well
it's like
they like a lot of liqueurs
brown drink well it's brown but what
does that mean i'm trying to save you oh
so i like uh
okay if something inspired by a show i
mean look we've all
been guilty of wanting a white russian
because of the best
that's a good one right there i'm
thinking okay don draper loves an
old-fashioned i'm more of a manhattan
guy but i definitely see him drinking
that i'm like i can go certain shows
make you want to drink certain authors
make you want to drink like yes it's
very like
as dingy as bukowski or hemingway's life
could be
their writing does make they do stylize
drunk life
so that makes you want to kind of drink
you watch mad men they bring in like a
tray of of like pre-made bloody marys
in those uh you know in the picture in
the picture
it looks cool [ __ ] it looks great with
the [ __ ] celery stock hanging out the
top oh it looks so good nothing looks
better on tv than a bloody mary i got
another one i mean you watch sideways
who doesn't want to get wine drinks
good point good so this is i think a
very good it took me a second to get it
now i'm like oh i see what he's saying
yeah yeah totally totally never had a
martini but when i watched the show mash
never never had a martini it's just
alcohol right there's nothing in it it's
just alcohol booze and la and olive
juice basically yeah it's just like a
shot that's a dirty martini but if you
have a
dry martini it's vermouth okay that's
true when i watch mash and when they put
olives in that martini yeah
yeah oh yeah the movie not the tv show
the movie yeah well you know it's uh a
martini will get you [ __ ] up
and they're good that's the problem it's
so good but it's just straight booze but
it's liquor yeah just taking shots and
it's in a fancy glass so you don't feel
as bad but you're just a drunk you're
right it really that's really what it is
it's just dressed up
problem this is a problem but it's in a
you know it's like a hot lady who's a
stripper in the game yeah there you go
that's a good noir
[Laughter]
okay we got one from sadie may here oh i
love sadie yo she's that artist not a
question but
tarantino movies ranked
most favorite to least favorite
at least top seven i know there's a lot
of this is i'm controversial
my top two are
true romance and kill bill well i don't
consider true romans a tarantino movie
okay i see where she's coming from but
that's that's fair i mean i'm not gonna
top three because we can't do all
eight of them whatever he's done all
right number one jackie brown number two
pulp fiction number three reservoir dogs
ballsy i love kill bill i love i love
tarantino i'm a bit you know what i
[ __ ] love once upon a time in
hollywood i loved it too
it's tough but those are my that's my
gut right there it's like go with the
gut jackie brown's phenomenal yeah that
one hits you it hits me hard because
it's it's kind of it's no movie of
tarantino's has more heart oh
it's like i love all of his work i think
he's an incredible filmmaker but i just
there's something about that movie that
like it's desperate
pam greer is a desperate character yes
yes robert uh forester is kind of a
desperate character it's his classic
thing where he casts people that kind of
like
i won't say down on their luck but they
kind of deserve more pam greer
uh robert forster and it's kind of like
iconic roles for both of them uh
yeah samuel l chris tucker samuel is so
funny
so funny so funny de niro in a weird
role weird and he's supposed to be
stallone is that right you turned it
down he turned down
down two tarantino movies why he turned
down death proof too where because he
just like i got girls i don't want to be
a guy who's like picking up women and
murdering them okay
but but he's a character though so i
don't know why he turned down jackie
brown huh interesting
how do you turn down tarantino some
people think he's a hack by the way i
know i think they all respect him i
think i'm not right i think it's more
like probably their insecurities like i
don't think i can do this well well yeah
i don't want to bring up bad blood but
uh
favro shits on tarantino a little bit in
swingers what does he remember that he's
like yeah he just bites everything from
scorsese and you're like this is back
when tarantino was so new and you're
like dude you don't know what what he's
going to be why he went for it i think
that was a joke because they ripped off
reservoir dogs in that movie yeah you
know that was the scene they all were
watching i remember but yeah i don't
know it felt right and then they ripped
off they don't know i think i think that
was kind of amazing was that a zing no i
think they were making fun of themselves
for themselves he shits on him and then
they all walk like in reservoir so
they're ripping off
and then they rip off scorsese when they
do the walking into the bar scene right
or the kitchen yeah yeah sorry so you
know i think i think that was playful
okay
but also tarantino is like
it's tough i i love all this stuff but
that's what my gut says that's a good
it's a good list but once upon a time
we're talking repot rewatch factor oh
it's so fun so fun the fight with bruce
lee brad pitt is great the the
the western scenes with leo or when he
has that meltdown with the drinking too
much incredible incredible so much
that's but my gut says
jackie brown hits me where it's like
better than pulp fiction i didn't say
better it said top for us i thought that
was a question you got to go personal i
love kill bill i think kill bill's
incredible
what uh i don't kill i don't i didn't
say i didn't say jackie brown is a
better film than pulp fiction i thought
this was our personal i don't consider
natural born killers a tarantino movie
either he just did the story he didn't
even do the script
what uh
i think he did the script did he yeah
and i think he produced it or something
what so okay what do you guys got i'm
going pulp yeah
then
hollywood then reservoir that's good
yeah i'm similar
pulp fiction reservoir dogs and then
hollywood really jackie brown maybe
three i don't know but this is jackie
brown's incredible yeah it's the
soundtrack rewatchability i think i've
watched that one the most the devil
fiction oh my god that's so good and
it's like it's also like the most
romantic champ street yeah yes that
little like well they it's romantic
because it's like casablanca where they
don't end up together yes that's what i
love about it like they kind of you
could tell they both liked each other
too much to end up together and pam bree
are so hot so hot so sexy but they liked
each other so much that they're like
let's leave it here that's [ __ ]
romantic yeah let's not let's not ruin
this we just pulled off a heist what are
we going to go on vacation together and
then pick at each other right in spain
good point they just pulled out the
heist of the century then they're just
hanging out in in maine like oh you chew
kind of loud yeah good point
wait a minute oh my lord yeah we can't a
lot of bosom
jesus h christ what are you doing sally
we're trying so
what are what are honorable i mean so
you don't put none of you put django or
inglorious and near the top three no two
far-fetched i agree i like those no i
like those i would go
uh glorious then django those that's
probably my next two
so you jackie brown is nowhere near the
top three i love jackie brown but ah
[ __ ] you're right i don't like the way
django ends
it's too too shoot-outy at the end what
about um
are we missing anything but i do live in
glorious i love brad pitt i love
christoph waltz i mean come on he's
amazing he i mean just him alone in that
movie puts me it puts it in my top five
and i love that he does
inglorious as the most hateable
character and then does django is the
most likable character yes it's kind of
a fun spin but what about i saw that in
the theater together we did that was fun
as hell that was super fun how about um
i've never seen the hateful late i got
to watch this that's pretty good yeah i
like it it's long it's drawn out but
it's good it's all dialogue at the end
which is his specialty sam jackson
[ __ ] rules oh yeah that guy's just
the best i mean you could argue
tarantino
thrust him into the
the
celebrity limelight because he was in a
couple of movies some spike leaflets
yeah but this really put him up up on
the top tier well he um he did that for
everybody though i mean he revitalized
careers too i mean apparently michael
madsen turned down
travolta's role in pulp fiction
big mistake but i'm glad he did because
travolta killed it travolta killed it
you don't give your lady a foot massage
i don't be tickling or nothing
do you ever hear the clip of michael
madsen on jim and sam they played it for
me once when i was on air
uh and michael madsen's like talking to
sam roberts and he's like well you never
hate your woman he's like what
and he's like you never slam her around
everybody's like of course not he goes
yeah okay
like he doesn't believe and you're just
like what he's that guy i think he he
chewed me out on jim and sam or op
michael madison yeah what'd he say to
him there's a clip somewhere but he i
made a joke and he's like you want me to
slap you in the mouth
what no thank you how have you not told
this story i don't i i don't know it was
so early in the morning i was hungover
and i was trying to be funny and he was
like who is this guy i'm going to slap
him in the mouth he said something like
that and i believed him like he has that
look where you're like he will hit me
i wonder i wonder if he's not a good guy
nah i think he's all right he's a great
actor i think he just lives old school
[ __ ] hitting women
most beautiful woman you don't have
slaves i'm old school
here it is there's all these actresses
nowadays who think i don't know what
point it is it could be great voice
wow but i was blown away i was like
happy to be there they don't even know
what beauty is i mean you can't touch
that can't wait for marketing trying to
make it
a little boring i remember she's a
lovely lady
you guys have been together a while too
20 years a little over 20 years yeah
yeah
i know it's around there how did you
meet her
um
oh well
she was in a gay bar
she glory hole
no i wouldn't go that far i mean in fact
if you say that again i smack you
i mean you can't see it in the room
he meant it yeah oh i could see it
he was like i'm gonna slap you how am i
telling that story and it takes mark
this long to tell that michael madsen
story you know how many guys have talked
about slapping me in the mouth
i've lost track fact they call his mouth
the glory hole
but uh god damn dude i met i met
tarantino on that show too wow
how was that well he was in like a weird
phase of like we need to stop the police
and black people are getting slaughtered
and like that's kind of what he talked
about the whole time
so
i would be like what about uh jackie
brown he was like yeah yeah speaking of
brown these brownies
come on
what about glorious masters let me tell
you about bastards yeah all cops are
bastards yeah so i didn't get a lot of
movie stuff out of them but i tried but
i got a photo with them cool dude great
guy legend yeah we might be drunk is
sponsored by break shot pool breakshop
pool is the only pool game on the app
store specifically designed to be played
between real-life friends
it's a fun and perky turn-based game and
completely non-intrusive no annoying ads
or forced in-app purchases we all hate
those right oh yeah with break shot pull
you can play pool with your friends
without needing to be online at the same
time when your friend plays you get a
notification that it's your turn to play
that's kind of cool yeah whenever you
feel like it this game is free and
in-app purchases are completely optional
even if you're not a gamer or even a
huge pool fan check it out you'll see
how fun it is i love pool i love uh i
mean i'm terrible at it but you know
it's fun it's a fun game
oh come on the sting i was in when i was
like
21 i was in a fry i got a free six-month
friars club uh
uh membership so i entered the pool
tournament i [ __ ] somehow
back words
even like the hustlers were like you
don't know how to play i can tell you on
the play but i won like two or three
rounds based on luck there you go and
then i met like a real guy and he just
did away with me but hey pool is great
uh it's available on ios and android ios
and android can even play against each
other you can play with friends no
matter what phone they have we
we might be drunk listeners who download
the game in the next week
we'll get a variety of in-game goodies
for free to make your experience even
better so go to the apple and android
app stores and search for brake shop
pool that's break shot one word
b-r-e-k-a-k sorry b-r-e-a-k
and pools and p-o-o-l they know what to
spell it probably yeah so that's one
more time that's break shot pool
uh you know and mark tell them how to do
it sure that's right folks download the
game and play already invite your
friends and show off your virtual pool
skills the developers are huge fans of
the pod thank you and would love to get
some we might be drunk fans to connect
with this cute game on their phones as
we might be drunk listeners you're
getting free goodies folks
the whole thing is free so give it a try
today and for those of you who can see
the video this is what the game looks
like on the store
check it out and get it now
it's a fun one okay we got another
question for you what else oh great oh
it's a p from jason jason peeves slow
refills ordered a mountain dew and it
comes with free refills when my cup is
empty that means i want to refill keep
them coming i completely agree jj yeah
we have this with coffee at a diner
you're like hello i'm an addict keep it
coming what are you doing it's an empty
cup here maybe maybe the waitress is
doing you a favor she's like hey how
many mountain dews do you need i mean
this is a [ __ ] that's how many are
you gonna have that's a lot that's a
good point yeah you know coffee makes
sense coffee like i need the cafe i
guess mountain dew's got caffeine but
well coffee is better for you than
mountain dew i remember doing a road gig
with joe list in like 2011 and he was
pounding mountain dews and i'm not gonna
lie i judged him a little bit i don't
blame him i was like mountain dew that's
why who are you nectar
yeah that is bad news mountain dew it's
just sugar and horseshit yeah that's bad
it does taste good it's great it's great
with a cocktail by the way i mean that's
you think that's white trash ever seen
someone drink a surge
it's been a minute holy [ __ ] surge
people look at mountain dew people like
all right mister
that's true i saw that once i left the
trailer
there's a nexus between this question
and the last one and it's steve buscemi
and reservoir dogs
when he says uh this waitress i'm not
giving her a tip because i've been here
half hour when was she only refilled my
cup six times oh that's right yeah six
times
yeah what a psycho and then like you got
a tip and then they go that's such a
great scene the dialogue the madonna
stuff
that was great
yeah tarantino does [ __ ] rule he
rules i mean just saw so much
so many movies that he just has this
ah great benjamin larkin an update on
the whiskey maybe no rush it's just been
a while since i've heard anything about
it well ben i'm sorry apparently when
you hire lawyers to do this stuff and
you want to get not completely [ __ ] in
the deal it takes a long long time yeah
who knew the red tape is real the fine
print the the legal stuff it's a
nightmare it's annoying you know mark
and i
we're in a career where we get instant
kind of feedback right
so we know and that's kind of what we
get used to so when you deal with
business stuff
it's pretty i mean you did a netflix
half but before that we you know we're
doing youtube it's all on our terms it
comes out when we want we're not dealing
with any red tape so when we deal with
any it's
fat cat's been a it's been an uphill
battle so we apologize for the weight we
were way too optimistic and yeah it's
still hopefully going to come out but
god damn is it taking long i know i had
a lady ask me about it last night so
it's coming but i do feel like the
distributor is dragging his feet a
little but yeah yeah yeah let's give his
address and see if people want to bother
yeah people want it it's a nice it's
nice that people actually care
diana hernandez
peeve calling me but not leaving a
voicemail i'm not gonna call you back
unless you tell me what you want and
just text me you freak yeah she's got a
point
it's true
the voicemail is big because it's like i
every time i get a phone call i assume
i'm in trouble or something bad happened
like you know i can attest that every
time i call him just out of the blue he
says not hello he says uh oh
nervous
but if you leave a voicemail i can go
oh i left my socks at your your bedroom
the only other person that calls them is
the std clinic that's right
no i'll tell you man i i i'm with you i
it drives me i tried to do a topical
joke the other night about the movie uh
scream
you know about like now he calls the
people and they're much younger so
they're just like i don't know this
number i'm not picking up yeah that's
the whole angle he's waiting to be like
i'm in the house i don't answer they're
like we don't text me if it's important
right you know but uh it's like
i'm with you i don't pick up i don't
know the number i almost never pick it
up and the if i don't it's rare that you
pick it up and it's good news it's true
it's never like you left a shitload of
money in this diner come meet it's
always like hey we need your uh 10.99 or
like hey uh this is the irs you owe us
uh forty thousand dollars it's always
some horse [ __ ] i know and you can't get
off the floor call the other day i was
like you know what [ __ ] it i'm an adult
i'm answering this and it was chase bank
and they're like we have some great
options for you you should come in and
sit down with us and i was like oh i'm
at the hospital i gotta go they're like
okay here call me back at the time and i
remember like what am i doing why am i
answering this call like this guy is
trying to get me to come into chase bank
like i should just hang up on the guy
right what do you do they always get you
at your lowest
yeah you're never you're never like
getting your dick sucked like let me see
who this is let me
it's always some [ __ ] i'm bored i'm
hungover and i'm like all right and they
get old people they prey on old people
because all people are like the landline
rings they're like hello and they're
like you should buy a home in tahiti
like maybe i should
it's pretty crazy it's a time share yeah
what happened to timeshare i feel like i
heard that that term a lot in the 90s i
think it's just a dumb deal yeah it's a
[ __ ] time share
everything's at times the world's a
[ __ ] timeshare am i right people i
think airbnb maybe have taken that space
i don't i'm not staying in an airbnb not
really like a hotel [ __ ] the air
like which are you more likely for them
to video tape
they got a camera in there they're
watching you jack off that's hot
watching you stick their airbrush in
your butthole while you're doing it
yeah i'm not trying to get sued
know i've stayed in some bad airbnb what
are you thinking well i was young and it
was like sixty dollars versus a hundred
and twenty so i was like all right i'll
just stay in the cheap hotel i would
stay in those shitty ass days in motel
type thing i should have done that
that's better i would i i never
also it's like such a headache to fill
out you're filling out all these forms
for an airbnb
it sucks and then nothing worse than
showering and other people's
you know shampoo bottles and luffa is
there you're like what am i doing oh i
just realized you guys don't vacation
that's why you don't do this when you go
on vacation you have an actual you know
family and you go out your airbnb you
don't stand i went on my first vacation
late december i did a nice little uh
resort thing i'm not airbnb sketch me
out i don't like staying in someone's
house hotel [ __ ] is set up for you it's
set up for a visitor a house so like
don't do this because this will fall
over and then this will happen you're
like what do i have to learn a whole
[ __ ] new uh place yeah the dog comes
in at six we walk the dog we won't even
bother you it's your place he's gonna
lick your [ __ ] while you're sleeping
it's he's friendly he likes you
wait so why do you get an airbnb with
the family
uh because staying in hotel is so like
impersonal
you have a yard your kid can run around
he can only get hard when he's looking
at uh photographs of a family yeah yeah
what does the kid think because he is
out no yeah yeah
all right he watches yeah
well it's just weird when you go yeah
there's family photos of people skiing
in lake tahoe and it's not your family
it is weird hey but that's what i do
with my wallet you know
i mean it is i'm not a big fan of the
airbnb i don't i don't like it and uh
interesting i remember i did it once uh
during the pandemic i was gonna do like
the very beginning i was doing phoenix
and end up getting canceled but like
i was like [ __ ] it i'm doing phoenix i'm
doing it right i'm getting a i'm going
to have some fun i'm getting a house
with a basketball court in a pool whoa
and i and then i was like i can't have
to cancel the gig so i'm just like oh
they just gave me like only some of the
money back i'm like this is why you do a
hotel
i hate corporations but they give you a
refund they give you a refund you're
right you know who's not giving you a
refund martha
but
hotel sex is great we can all agree but
sex in someone else's house
that's a lot of fun is it oh i look at
the photos
i put it in front of her well i go doggy
i don't know i've had a couple great uh
airbnbs in la like up at the hills you
get the hollywood hills or whatever that
is laurel canyon had some great nights
uh and those b and b's yeah and there's
a fireplace there's something i love a
fireplace love a fireplace fireplaces
are fun man and i'm not gonna lie i've
eaten a lot of people's food at airbnb
they're like they leave it out like he
won't eat this and i'm like oh i'm
eating it you eat their food oh i eat
their food i love when i stay in a in a
like a comedy condo back in the day and
another comic was there before you can
you just i guess you just guess where
they were from yeah by the [ __ ] in the
fridge you'd be like almond milk la act
you know that's so true yeah yeah
sardines canadian
[Laughter]
that's so true yeah i eat all that [ __ ]
too you would eat the [ __ ] in the fridge
from the you don't know how old that is
you sniff it
so
when i sit down at a table at the cellar
with mark just like let's sit down here
and there's a
bowl of borscht speaking of sniff sorry
i'm listening no you're not
a bowl of borscht so
uh yeah we'll sit down at any random
table at the seller and they're like
let's clean this table off for you and
mark's like no no i'll finish this up
and just eat somebody's borscht ah
yes that's i mean that's insane that's
the covet vaccine i get a little of it
in me
it cures me
i never get sick
you don't ever get sick no no
it's interesting i think i had omicron
but it was two days i [ __ ] it out back
to normal i think i had it too is it the
diarrhea in december it's like the body
aches are the real like those muscle
aches that's really the type
of wine ah true
i got a good speaking of eggs i got a
good wreck for you oh hit me
uh so i went to you know physical
therapy the other day there's an old
lady there
[ __ ] trying to remember her last name
i think i could figure it out if you
want to look her up like an actress yeah
she's in her 80s and she's and she's
just chatting me up she's a character uh
you know anything
i'm gonna look up her name it's marilyn
something it's uh
marilyn
[Music]
so she's a physical therapy with me and
i think i'm allowed to say this right
this is fine oh yeah she's familiar she
was on sesame street she starts
obsessing jokes
and she's doing the voices and [ __ ] and
she we just chat i guess my therapist
told her i was a comic so she's like you
you should talk to sam he'll like you
and we just you know she's a character
man she's making me laugh she goes i got
a joke for you and you know usually you
dread this moment but i could kind of
tell it'd be funny coming out of hers
yeah but the joke she tells me she's a
woman in her 80s she goes so a guy's
trying to [ __ ] his wife she goes i can't
have sex with you i'm seeing the
gynecologist tomorrow and he goes oh i'm
sorry do you have a dental appointment
too
that's a joke she tells me
so part of my wreck is like
talk to people it's important to talk to
people
for your brain i think
sometimes this pandemic has made us so
inward and i think the twitter [ __ ] is
so toxic you're just you're just kind of
in your head assuming the worst it's
good to talk to human beings so anyway i
look her up afterwards because i'm like
i'm curious she's in a lot of [ __ ] yeah
look at this imdb list is crazy she's in
the front with woody out front i made
you watch that that's a great movie
movie communism one of the only times
you hear woody allen say go [ __ ]
yourself that's right and zero mostel
that's a classic yeah sesame street law
and order
uh wow barney miller sex in the city
there it is yeah she's been around good
character pretty cool yeah she was very
very nice and cool so that's a good
wreck i agree people are kind of like
movies like give them a shot
you know you can turn it off in 10
minutes or you can
get the [ __ ] out of there with a person
but sometimes you meet crazy fun
interesting people and they give you a
tidbit you would have never known
yeah that's important i'm gonna wreck
and i see we've done two sesame street
references i watched the
sesame street doc i think you've wrecked
this before ah i could be wrong yeah you
might be right matt peters has he has he
wrecked it before or no
okay maybe maybe you just wrecked it to
me in person maybe yeah
very interesting very cool talk about
the industry
a bunch of like senators in alabama try
to shut it down because i had a lot of
black people on the show
very interesting
i love the big deal you might have is it
a jim henson dock or a sesame street
sesame street oh i think you wrecked the
jim henson oh maybe that might have been
that yeah i like henson
mark street gang how we got the sesame
street that's it yeah really cool and
just starting from scratch it was like a
show show and they did all these tests
with kids and the kids were just like
puppets more puppets so they're like all
right [ __ ] the show we're just going all
puppets wow and they did all these focus
groups just like jeff dunham yeah
exactly
and uh really interesting like
starting from scratch didn't know what
the hell they were doing and figured it
out and then became the biggest show on
the planet wow cool doc
i love the the store that's why i like
the brillstein book because it's just i
love the
the beginning of everything because
everything is huge had a beginning elvis
presley had a beginning you know
everything started from somewhere
michael jackson you know everyone had to
pay dues everybody everybody got yelled
at everybody got rejected dr seuss was
rejected 11 times and he became a rabid
anti-semite so yeah you got to start
somewhere
is that real rule doll
he could imagine a [ __ ] big fugly
giant but not a friendly jew apparently
that was his problem that's true we did
a chocolate factory yeah yeah yeah the
jews went in they said it was too drafty
but yeah yeah so i love the origin story
so great great little doc james new
giant piece you go you call this a peach
giant
what are you getting look bigger in the
pictures that's all i'm saying
oh you got a you got a bit
oh that's really good uh oh
good bit really seems to kiss
here we go with a bit um
did we do a peeve
uh did someone else's peeves i believe
ah
i got one peeve i just gotta get this
out and i'll leave it alone
you ever have this one guy goes
meet me at the coffee shop at two i go
i'll be there
he hits me up at 1 40. where are you
i'm on the way to the coffee shop oh all
right all right i'm like we said two
right yeah two
well then why the [ __ ] you yelled at me
it's not even two yet yeah you say i'm
here early yeah so if you happen to be
in the neighborhood come see me now but
yeah yeah the expectation that you just
be there early exactly 20 minutes early
i was like you're an early guy too i try
to get there early but you're very
punctual i'm very nice
my dad was terrifying if i was late so
i'd be beaten into me even worse to your
sister but uh yeah so
i i got i got the where are you i'm like
i got 20 minutes
yeah weird yeah it bugs me a little bit
yeah i'm also always like these days in
the winter i'm always a little later
just because you feel like you had to
grab more it takes a little longer to
get ready the summer you're just
throwing shorts and you run out but
right it's 10 degrees the other night
you're throwing on you're like yeah i'm
going to layer up yeah and i have a
subconscious thing where when it's cold
out it takes me a little longer to get
out there because you're you're you're
kind of nervous you're dreading it a
little bit you're dreading it it's like
jumping into a cold pool you're just
kind of exactly the hot dub you just get
right in jump right in yeah you ruined
you were in their vacation me and me and
a married couple yeah [ __ ] your airbnb
i don't yeah i got i think i got a bit i
got a couple bit i don't know have i
ever done this one on this show matt
peters let me know if uh if i'd done
this one i i saw a bumper sticker it
said i got an abortion i'm proud and i
was like proud have i done this yeah
well i was just like you're proud like i
feel shame when i jack off
i don't know are you proud of an [ __ ]
like i'm for a woman's right to choose
it's just a weird thing to be like proud
of right so
i'm thinking of other angles where it's
like the government has never tried to
stop you from masturbating i'm like well
that's not true there was one time i was
five hours at the dmv
i don't know i got like a better ending
but like the government has never i hear
that the government has never tried to
stop you from masturbating well she only
killed one potential kid and you killed
a million potential that's true and at
the dmv if you jerk off that is a form
of id
that's a good tag that's a good tag yeah
technically they tried to arrest me but
i said you know technically that's that
is my dna
there you go technically that's that's
more than a passport that's better than
a drop yeah that's perfect all right
take it is that is that maybe something
yeah something yeah i like that all
right what do you get that's not hitting
that's cute no it's something it just
needs more it needs like another thing
it's part of a bigger abortion chunk
yeah that's a funny sentence my fetus
yeah
i like the dmv angle that's a good point
um
that's funny
oh yeah an abortion hot button i did
some i was in texas i did some abortion
jokes and you could feel the
feel the heat i love it yeah yeah i was
doing something in texas too i loved it
what was that when you had there that
was really good
oh the freedom are you across the border
i said to a guy so what's your favorite
part about uh i said freedom i said yeah
the freedom to drive to oklahoma to get
an abortion yeah that's what i said got
a pretty good laugh but then uh
yeah that was fun what uh
what do you got mark
this is bits a little long-winded i
think this here it hits once and it
bombs once and it hits once and it bombs
once so maybe you guys can help me out
basically i talk about how the phone is
supposed to make life easier it makes my
life way harder because everything you
have to have a login a password a pin
number
uh you know all this [ __ ] and it's all
the [ __ ] i need i can't get into bank
account healthcare
car insurance all this [ __ ] i can't get
into because of the phone cause i forgot
my password but all the [ __ ] i don't
need in life
is very easy to get prostitute right on
the corner you never go to a process
like hey can i you want to get in the
car she's like you got an account with
us like no no she's like you got to
download snapchat like ah or snatch chat
or whatever it's such a good point you
want to vax you want you want to get a
covered test you got to fill out a form
you got to uh get the uh whatever you
call it the scan thing yeah scan code qr
code you want some crack right here yeah
yeah that's the joke i go up to a
coke dealer and i'm like hey can i get
he's like you got an account i'm like no
but i go i use you all the time he's
like what's your mom's maiden name i'm
like i just want a bump he's like how
many of these are fire extinguishers i'm
like ah you know
but it needs more it's it's i can see
when i'm doing it the crowd is like okay
okay but it's not really there yet yeah
something about like meth like you're
you're missing your teeth and you're
like this is my id you know me oh yeah
with no teeth facial recognition yeah
facial i don't understand the conceit of
the joke i understand your examples i
don't understand what the heart is the
heart of it is bad stuff is easy to get
[ __ ] i need like health care and all
that you have to fill out forms and have
an id and have a pin number and a login
and like dunkaroos are right there for
you when you need them junk food
fast food very easy to get it is harder
to be
healthy it's really that yeah it comes
down to it and responsible
like i had a car insurance issue
recently and they were what's your
number and i was like oh hold on let me
get the app by the way you have car
insurance but you don't have health
insurance well you care more about your
car
than yourself well the car they arrest
you if you don't have it health
insurance they don't
i wouldn't have car insurance if it
wasn't
a you know legal thing mark's gonna be
the richest guy to get into a car crash
and have a gofundme
for my body the car will be covered
i don't have collision but my point is
it's easy easy to get bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] you need and you're supposed to
have and legal [ __ ] is very hard to do
that's my point it's funny premise yeah
so the point is you go up to a cokehead
a coke dealer and it's he just here's a
20. boom you're golden
but car insurance are like what's your
account what's your
vin number all that [ __ ] i'm out they
don't want to give you a second to
second guess the bad decision
ah
right
because then you won't get it yeah no
one's filling out a form for coke
right like no one's filling out like
you're getting a prostitute that's like
you could change your mind a second
yeah
you don't want to rethink the bad thing
i think i think that's i think that's
the
that's a good point with other stuff
with car insurance you're like well i
could get hurt
right they want you to overthink that um
and they make it a law yeah you have to
have it
huh okay
i'll keep noodling i'm
the joke's like 80
i just need to
tweak and retool tweak dude yeah so it's
getting there
i will say a lot of the the drunks at
home have been giving me some tags
pretty solid oh yeah can you take that
one can you think of a good one no
but uh i get a ton and i'm like some of
you're like this is horrific don't ever
call me again
you're like that's not bad
yeah the comments are great on your
youtube
very creative funny stuff listeners yeah
funny sean padden i saw him last night
he goes man you're
the fans of your show are so creative
and i was like they really are it's like
they're it's inspiring to us man look at
the picture behind you that was drawn by
a fan or painted by a federal we're very
lucky we appreciate you guys very much
well we love the arts we love broadway
music we love jazz we love movies so i
love it man we love you guys
plug some dates dude
oh and listen listen to patreon
patreon.com we might be drunk pod email
us at uh we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com we love you here here uh i'm
all over the place marknormancomedy.com
check it out check out the stand ups on
netflix the half hour is doing well
uh tag me and tag netflix just so they
know that there's a buzz
uh columbus ohio i'm doing a theater in
raleigh at theater in cleveland
all kinds of fun stuff
uh la jolla tampa
omaha kansas city sacramento
uh a lot of fun stuff cooking chicago
this summer providence this summer a lot
of good stuff
check it out out to lunch
hit him huntsville alabama hartford
connecticut la jolla sacramento
um
what else do i have uh orlando
west palm columbus salt lake city
um and the big one mesa oh yeah may 7th
weekend it's it's selling it'll be sold
out soon so keep
[Music]
nashville
whoa
uh albany
all that [ __ ] toronto samurai.com
shows get on it who does your website
um
really it's it's someone that's my agent
uh caitlyn does it really yeah oh [ __ ] i
gotta get my agent on that oh i'm at the
danny improv too we got all the same
dates oh yeah dania that's right
yeah i'm at west palm beach we're
circling each other yeah i'm all over
florida so oh miami i'm doing miami
again
so yeah tell a friend spread the word
get on the patreon keep drinking send us
whatever you got we'll take it thanks to
the beer jew sally peters peters we love
you gotham studios you're the truth we
love being here hell yeah uh yeah keep
listening guys we appreciate you thanks
for the teddy grahams and shout out to
anton antoine's cookies for the [ __ ]
the the killer stuff i'm hosting these
candles some hangover candles oh we love
you
and you know we love you because you
guys aren't paying us but you're sending
us your [ __ ] and we love it so we're
plugging it hell yeah
all right keep it real bye
comedy
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you